hello and welcome to M coding I'm James
Murphy today we're talking about
functions within functions variable
Scopes and closures in Python
of course don't forget to subscribe so
that more people can see my content
let's start with this example that looks
complicated but by the end I'm sure
you'll be able to get it
the question is what's going to happen
when we run this function level six
we've got these two functions donkey
and chonky
donkey defines another inner function
which it ends up returning
chunky calls donkey to get that inner
function and then calls the inner
function with an argument
so ultimately the function returns some
Call of this inner function
but the complexity or confusion of it
all comes from the fact that we have
multiple different X y's and Z's
floating around all the place
inner has a parameter y so that one's
easy that's just a local variable but x
and z need to come from somewhere else
it might use this Global X or maybe it
takes this local X because when the
function is actually called remember
it's the return results of this donkey
call the nearest enclosing scope might
seem like it's the scope of this chunky
function as for Z since the inner
function is defined before this C maybe
it uses this outer Z
or maybe it somehow gets this inner
donkey Z or maybe it wants this donkey Z
but it can't have it because it's not
defined yet so maybe we get an error
feel free to take a moment and pause if
you want to work out the example
yourself but if you're already confused
and you know you're not going to get the
answer don't worry this is a tricky part
of python that doesn't come up that
often and as such even experienced
programmers don't get a lot of practice
with it and may not know what the rules
are so what answer do we actually get
the answer in this case turns out to be
that it uses the global value of x of
course it uses the past argument of Y
and it uses this value of Z in the
donkey function that was defined after
the inner function was defined
we're going to start off with much
simpler examples than this but once you
know the rule even this example will
make complete sense to you
we'll start off with some simpler
examples but I want you to keep in mind
the key to understanding these is the
compile time of python
that's right compile time
a very common misconception is that
python is not compiled it's interpreted
in fact it is compiled and it's also
interpreted
a module source is first compiled to
bytecode then The Interpreter interprets
the bytecode at runtime
we often don't realize that this
compilation is happening first because
it happens automatically
how variable scoping Works inside nested
functions is one of the few features
that depends on the separation of
compile time and runtime Behavior
here's the one rule that you need to
remember in order to make sense of all
of these examples
variable lookups happen at runtime but
where python will look for the variable
is determined at compile time
let's start simple and work our way up
level one we just say return X and
there's no X argument the only X Insight
is the global X
the code for every function is compiled
at compile time
there are no assignments to X in this or
any enclosing function scope so the
compiler decides that it will look in
the global namespace for this X
of course you didn't need this video to
tell you that this one you probably
expected
level two once again we're just
returning X
but in this case we take an argument V
and if V is truth e we assign a local
variable X
otherwise we don't assign to X
so which X is returned
remember where we look for X needs to be
determined at compile time
the compiler doesn't use any information
about the argument V
the compiler simply notes that somewhere
in this function I assign to X
therefore everywhere in this function X
is treated as a local variable
of course that means if we pass in
something truthy then we get the x
equals local X and then return that X
but if we pass in something policy we
get an error
the compiler determined that X was a
local variable
we tried to return that local variable
but we never gave it a value
that's why we're getting this Unbound
local error
it doesn't matter that there was a
perfectly good variable named X in the
global scope
it was determined at compile time that
it wasn't going to use that X it's going
to use the local one
all right let's keep going
level three
here we Define our outer Z our inner
function which only takes Y and returns
X Y and Z and then we call the inner
function with a given argument
at compile time the compiler says there
is no local variable X in this inner
function there is no local variable X in
this level 3 function therefore it will
look for an X in the global scope
there is a y in this local scope so it
will use that local y
and for Z there's no Z in the local
scope so it determines that it will use
this C from the outer scope
and not too surprisingly indeed we see
the global X the Y argument and the
outer Z
okay but what if we defined inner first
and then to find Z afterwards
we do not get an error even though Z
isn't defined when the function is
defined
once again at compile time the compiler
decides that X is going to be found in
the global scope Y is going to be found
in the local scope and Z is going to be
found in the outer scope
it doesn't matter where the assignment
and the outer scope is
somewhere in the scope of the level 3
function Z is assigned a value
that means everywhere it's treated as a
local variable of the level 3 function
so python decides that this Z will refer
to that local variable
but remember it doesn't look up the
value of the variable until runtime
the runtime for this function is here
when it's actually called and by that
time Z is defined
so just as before we see the global X
the Y argument and the outer Z even
though that outer Z wasn't defined at
the time the function was defined
just to repeat the rule again it's
because variable lookups happen at
runtime but where python will look for
the variable is determined at compile
time
let's drive this one home in level four
here we Define an outer Z
then our inner function
then a new value for Z
then we call the function
so which value of Z does it use
there you see it it uses the second one
even though at this point when the
function is defined Z already had a
value the inner function does not use
that value
instead python says the value of Z will
be looked up in the outer function scope
whenever the functions run whenever the
value Z is accessed
by the time the function is run in this
call the second outer Z has already been
set so it finds that value
now this might be where you start
feeling like something is kind of fishy
how does it know
What If instead of calling this function
right here I had just returned the
function and then called it a million
lines later
isn't Z just a local variable that's
going to disappear and be garbage
collected once the function returns
here's where we need to talk about
closures
traditionally a closure is an object
that wraps up a function with some kind
of extra environment
in this case the environment would be
some kind of thing grouped together with
the inner function that keeps a
reference to this Z variable keeping it
from being garbage collected
unfortunately this is one of those cases
where there are multiple definitions of
a closure floating around
some people use closure to mean the
function together with its environment
other people including the people that
wrote python use closure to mean just
the environment part
ing out the closure of the inner
function we see that it's a tuple
containing a single element which is a
cell
python determined at compile time that
this cell is where the value of Z is
going to be stored
the cell has a reference to a string
object which is going to be the first
outer Z because we're printing it before
we Define the second outer Z
printing out the closure again after we
assign the second outer Ze we see that
the cell object itself hasn't changed it
has the same address
however the string object that it's
referencing has changed
this use of a cell instead of the object
itself is how python ensures that you
always get the latest value of Z at
runtime
because the inner function only
references the cell and not the string
object itself this ensures both that
when we run the function we get the
latest value of Z
and it means that we can Define the
inner function even when the value of Z
isn't defined yet
in that case we see that the cell is
just empty
then once we Define a value of Z it gets
put in the cell
also note that we only have one cell for
Z
the global variable X does not get a
cell
for Global variables python stores a
reference to the global namespace in
which the function was defined
that means that even if you pass this
inner function off somewhere else and
call it from a different module it will
still look up Global variables in the
module that it was defined in
of course this achieves a very similar
effect to the closure attribute
the global variable X doesn't need to be
defined at the time I Define this
function when I call the function the
most recent value will be looked up in
the global dictionary
and if my inner function didn't
reference Z meaning it doesn't have any
references to any non-local variables
then the closure attribute would just be
set to none
let's move on to level five
the point of level 5 is to show you that
although functions are compiled at
compile time meaning their source is
translated into bytecode at compile time
actual function objects that get hooked
up to that bytecode are created at
runtime
that's what the def keyword does
death does not compile a new function
def creates a new function object with
the given name and hooks it up to the
pre-existing bytecode
that means every call to level 5 defines
its own copy of the inner function each
of these copies is distinct and has its
own closure
every call to level 5 has its own cell
for its own copy of Z
therefore the closures for each copy of
the inner function can refer to
completely different Z's
so in this call we pass in n equals zero
this call we pass in n equals one in the
first call we see outer Z zero and in
the second one we see outer Z1
of course this is probably what you
expected to happen in this simple case
since there's only one Z floating around
and now we're back to level six
let's just follow the rules
there's no assignment to X in enter
there's no assignment to X in Donkey
there's no assignment to X in level six
X will be looked up in the global scope
of this module
Y is a parameter of the function it'll
be looked up as a local variable
there's no assignment to Z and enter But
there is an assignment to Z in Donkey
therefore the C will reference the cell
in Donkey which eventually gets set to
Doc easy and is never modified again
we return the function and because that
function's closure is referencing the
cells it's pointing to this donkey Z
that cell is not garbage collected and
it continues to point to the value
donkey Z
in chunky we call donkey and the inner
function gets assigned to the value of f
the X here is irrelevant the inner
function will always look in the global
scope that was determined to add compile
time
when we call F we pass in Y which is
that local variable
and Z is still referencing the cell that
points to donkey Z so we'll see donkey Z
therefore when we print this out we'll
see global X Y ARG and Donkey Z now that
you know the rule it's not so bad right
before we get to the final level seven
I'd like to go over a few odds and ends
first up what about lambdas and
comprehensions
although lambdas are syntactically a
very different way of defining functions
you don't give them a name they kind of
have to be one line
they have this implicit return statement
and Lambda is an expression not just a
statement like a death is but ultimately
lambdas are just functions it's fancy
syntactic sugar for defining a function
without giving it a name
all of the scoping rules for lambdas are
exactly the same as for a function
so the rules for this Lambda
would be the same as for this function
the code in the body gets compiled to
bytecode add compile time variable
lookups happen at runtime but where
python will look for the variables is
determined at compile time
next up comprehensions
I'm going to use a list comprehension
but it's the same for any of them
you may not have realized it before by
defining a comprehension is defining a
function and immediately calling it
this comprehension is semantically
equivalent to this
which is equivalent to this defining a
generator and then passing that into
list
and this part defining the generator
is more or less equivalent to this
it defines a generator function and
gives you an instance of it
the scoping rules for generator
functions are exactly the same as for
normal functions
so whenever you use a comprehension just
pretend you've got a generator function
there and use the normal scoping rules
these cases usually aren't very
confusing since they're typically very
short in this case X is treated as a
local variable since the for Loop
assigns to X and the last thing we need
before our last example is what do
non-local and Global do
non-local and Global don't actually
correspond to any operation that happens
at runtime
by default the compiler would determine
on its own whether each variable was a
local variable a non-local variable or a
global variable
because we assigned to X in this
function the compiler would normally
assume that this is a local variable
non-local X instructs the compiler to
treat X as a local variable of some
enclosing function scope rather than a
local variable of the current function
scope so this assignment will actually
change the value in this function
in our first print statement we see the
non-local X calling the function changes
the value of x to the overwritten
non-local that's the return value so we
see it once then we print out X again so
we see that indeed its value has changed
then in main I'm also printing out the
global X so we can see that it hasn't
changed
let's change this to Global X
the first print we'll see non-local are
called f will change the global value of
x and return it then when we print this
x again we'll still see the non-local X
because in this function X is a local
variable
but when we get to the global print
we'll see its value has changed
so indeed we see non-local then the
overwritten global the non-local again
and the overridden Global the lookup
rules are exactly the same it's just
that you get to override the compiler if
it would have made a choice that you
didn't want this is typically only
needed if you want to assign to a
variable from an outer scope within an
inner function if you're just reading
the variable what the compiler does is
usually the most sensible thing but if
you really Shadow your variables a lot
you might end up using this so I'd say
if you're using Global to just read a
value then the real solution is to just
choose a better name that doesn't
conflict with a global variable or
better yet to not use a global variable
in the first place if you don't have to
so finally we come to level seven please
please please do not do this
but if you understand the rules it's a
straightforward application that you
should be able to understand why you get
the output that you do
take a moment to think about it and
comment below I'm just gonna blast right
ahead okay inside level 7 we Define
please don't do this
this defines some generator and it
returns an instance of the generator
along with this Lambda returning a
because of this monstrosity a is
determined to be a local variable of the
please don't do this function
it doesn't matter this code will never
execute because there's an assignment to
a somewhere in the function a is treated
as a local variable of that function
inside the generator we explicitly Mark
a non-local every time we unpause the
generator this updates the value of a
because a was non-local that refers to
this a inside this Lambda a is also
treated as non-local because we don't
assign to it so it finds this a then we
return the generator and the Lambda
whose closures both point to this empty
a in the outer code we grab out the
generator and Lambda if we call the
function first then we get a name error
cannot access free variable a where it
is not associated with a value in
enclosing scope a was pointing to a cell
that cell was empty that's why we're
getting this error but if we run the
generator first then print the function
we see the value 0.
every time we call next on the generator
it updates the value of a
and whenever we print the function it
gives us whatever the current value of a
is
just imagine the person who's got a bug
in their code
and they track it down to the source and
they find this Lambda that just returns
a
but every time they call it they just
seem to get a different value
gotta say that would be a pretty bad day
for that developer
so anyway like comment subscribe thanks
for watching thanks to Kevin for
submitting the donkey chunky example
and as always thank you to my patrons
and donors if you really enjoy my
content please do consider becoming a
patron or donor it does help me out so
please go forth with this knowledge and
never do this
see you next time